Let's pray together over day 32, holiness as
empowerment.
Oh Lord,
you are the powerful and the awesome God.
We have seen you do amazing and mighty things in our salvation,
in our spiritual growth, and we pray, oh God, for an
empowerment
to witness and to bear witness to your work in
our life,
in our hearts. Lord, would you give us courage?
Would you give us boldness like the disciples who
were so fearful before
they saw Jesus and before they were filled with the Holy Spirit.
They were fearful, but afterwards they were bold because they had the presence
and the power of the Holy Spirit as their comforter there with
them to make them bold. Oh God, refill us as your
church again and make us bold like you are bold.
Make us confident like the disciples were confident.
Make us passionate about people
hearing the Word of God like Isaiah was when he said, "Here am I, send
me." Lord, don't let us be timid,
scarable, cowering people, but instead,
Lord, fill your church with the Holy Spirit.
Fill me with your Holy Spirit. Fill my friend
here praying with me with the Holy Spirit so that we
might not be unequal to the task in front of us,
so we can be burdened and powerful.
And oh Lord, blow open the doors
between us and the world as believers.
Don't let the Holy Spirit be this thing that shuts us in
quietly and
makes us monks in a monastery somewhere, but
instead send us out with power and with courage and with
boldness to speak the Word of God with courage and
with forthrightness to our world. We need that.
So do it for us today, we pray in Jesus' name.
Let's continue praying and seeking the Lord together.